[Music]
did you hear the news
astronomers wielding the biggest
telescope ever invented the event
horizon telescope managed to take a
snapshot of the monster black hole at
the center of our milky way galaxy
today i'm going to take you on a deep
dive into what this means for our
understanding of matter gravity and our
galaxy itself let's go into the
impossible
[Music]
if you're new to my channel welcome i'm
brian keating the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at uc
san diego i'm an experimental
cosmologist who builds telescopes and
takes them all around the world from the
south pole to chile to california and
even to far-flung places like outer
space today's announcement literally
shook up the world not only for
professional astronomers like me but for
amateurs lay people every curious human
being just like you the event horizon
telescope was constructed in the past 10
years
and in 2019 made a stunning announcement
the first ever image of the so-called
event horizon of a black hole
black holes are the most mysterious
objects in the universe they've been
awarded multiple nobel prizes for
discoveries ranging from ligo to the
theoretical underpinnings of their
mathematical structure to sir roger
penrose we've even seen images in the
optical and near infrared thanks to
telescopes run by andrea guezz and
reinhard genzel using adaptive optics in
the infrared wavelength regime today's
press conference shook up the universe
it showed magnificent images that shed
light pun intended you're a funny guy
on the most mysterious objects we know
about these black holes are the subject
of great controversies perhaps
responsible for our deepest
understanding of how gravity can be
unified with quantum mechanics black
holes have implications for the
destruction of information something
that's forbidden by quantum mechanics
they have relevance to thermodynamics to
entropy and even our understanding of
time
sometimes black holes are even thought
to be the source of dark matter in the
universe although we've known for quite
some time that black holes can't
contribute very much to the amount of
dark matter there is in the universe
even the most massive black hole that
we've ever imaged using the event
horizon telescope in 2019 the black hole
at the core of m87 which weighs in at a
whopping 2 billion times the mass of our
sun m87s huge black hole mass makes it
really a monster that black hole is
dwarfed by almost a trillion more stars
in m87 the black hole only represents
about 0.1.2 of the mass of that
particular galaxy and the same is true
of the milky way galaxy that today's
results pertain to galaxies like the
milky way actually orbit not because of
the black hole at their center but
because of the vast amount of dark
matter which far dwarfs the amount of
black hole mass in our galaxy in past
interviews with heino falca and shep
dolmen on this channel we discussed the
phenomenon of the so-called light shadow
or event horizon which was discovered by
the same team using the same telescope
array a series of radio telescopes
ranging from the south pole antarctica
called the south pole telescope to the
neighbor of the bicep telescope of
antarctica all the way to chile and
other telescopes throughout the planet
constructing a planetary sized telescope
that allows scientists with very small
wavelengths millimeter wavelengths to
image the black hole and his properties
now m87 is about 60 million light years
away in the virgo cluster it's a
behemoth with a trillion stars five
times as many as the milky way galaxy
and the black hole at its core is about
two million times the mass of our sun
and the black hole in the milky way
galaxy called sagittarius a star
discussed in today's press conference is
only only quote unquote about 6 million
times the mass of our sun so there's
almost 500 times more mass in the galaxy
called m87s black hole than in the milky
way galaxy's black hole which is why
they probably made that discovery first
and that announcement came in 2019 as
opposed to 2022. on those scales the
black hole itself is minimally small now
the benefit of sagittarius a star is
that it's closer to us and astronomical
signals often decay as the inverse
square or sometimes even higher powers
of the distance from the object to the
observer here on earth the smaller size
of the sagittarius a-star black hole
meant that light traverses it in a much
shorter amount of time far far shorter
than the time that it would take for a
light to traverse the black hole in m87
meaning that in just about 20 minutes
you could get many images of how the
dynamics of this black hole are changing
you could effectively make a movie
because of the black hole's compact size
you couldn't do this with m87 as cool as
that was upcoming results in combination
with the infrared images of sagittarius
a star from andrea guezza's group and
reinhardt denzel's group make for an
amazing so-called multi-messenger
astronomical extravaganza we're using
multiple wavelength range each providing
a unique fingerprint a rosetta stone
contribution if you will whatever
metaphor you like to better understand
the properties of gravity of space times
radical curvature at these behemoth size
skills yes come on
what an amazing time to be alive as an
utterly new window on the cosmos is
opened thanks to stunning new technology
like adaptive optics polarization
sensitivity and very long baseline
interferometry using a planetary size
telescope you can watch the whole press
conference at the link in the video
description below i've also had
conversations as an experimentalist with
the leaders of this event horizon
project telescope now these team leaders
that i've conversed with including shep
dolmen and heino falca provide amazing
insight into what it's like to actually
build this technology and operate it and
not least a ball analyze the data from
it so that we truly can understand what
gravity behaves like in the most extreme
circumstances in the known universe
so let me know in the comments what
black hole do you think the event
horizon telescope should turn its
powerful eye to next
check out this playlist combining my
conversations with phenomenal brilliant
theorists like delilah gates like
cameron vapha and with juan maldasena
about the properties of black holes and
what they teach us about entropy time
dynamics as well